the U.S economy is certainly giving off
a lot of mixed signals right now on one
hand there's a banking crisis that has
to Mark its teetering but there's also
some positive signs as well
I spoke to Max wolf an economist here in
New York City to try to make sense of it
all
most Americans are nervous some are
really suffering and no one really knows
exactly what's going on inflation was a
big deal last year where it reached over
nine percent in June in response to
Federal Reserve raised interest rates
and it did the job bringing inflation
down to about six percent where it is
today but that's still high because most
economists say the target is around one
to two percent inflation will be less of
a problem going forward but we have a
lot of instability risk around the
global supply chain and around the
conflict in in Russia and Ukraine higher
interest rates might have helped slow
inflation but it's also had a negative
effect on that housing market that's
because interest rates during the
pandemic were down to Historic lows of
about two percent today they're up to
about seven percent
but I think the housing Market's best
days for a while are probably in the
rear view mirror not the windshield and
Americans are working the U.S added over
500 000 jobs just in January and over
300 000 in February the unemployment
rate of 3.4 percent was the lowest since
1969. and since Americans are working
they're also spending money at a record
Pace as well so what are we to make of
all these conflicting signs of this
economy every time we see a piece of
data we have to try to figure out if
this is the new normal usual or abnormal
that's usually how we look at things in
economics is this the beginning of
something new the end of something old
or something we haven't seen before the
confounding U.S economy certainly giving
off mixed signals everywhere